that's why it's not useful to be envious  of people  you know you see some you're a young man  you see someone drive by in a ferrari  with blonde and you think my god he's  got everything and you know the woman in  the car is a prostitute who's got a  cocaine addiction and her her life is  just one catastrophe after another and  he's had to lie and cheat his way into  this position and he's afraid that  everything's going to come crashing down  on him and that's what you're jealous of  and it's just not that  profound  you don't want someone else's fate man  your fate's enough and your adventure's  enough it's plenty it's more than you  can ever fully realize